great new cbs comedy from producer chuck
lore it's called be
positive now the series revolves around
a therapist named drew and his
adventures trying to protect
a wild woman named gina who just happens
to be his
future kidney donor all right so joining
me to talk about this series are the
stars thomas middleditch and annalee
ashford hi thomas hi emily
hello hello hello hello thank you so
much for being with us thomas i want to
start with you the show we're told has
was inspired by the experiences of the
creator of the show
marco pinette did he find out that he
really did need a new kindy and an old
acquaintance volunteered her own
that's precisely the story yeah and
there was
some growing things along the way they
had to uh they had to teach each other
a thing or two but now uh they are
bound for life they're dear friends they
marco make sure to call her every week
it's actually a really sweet story
when this is done i will not call
annalee ever again
[Laughter]
but it's nice that marco has that
relationship okay so we know uh both of
you from some of your previous work uh
thomas nominated uh for an emmy from
silicon valley anna lee you want a tony
and
you can't take it with you so what was
the draw to be part of a network
sitcom
well this is sort of the best of the
best of the bestest when it comes to
network sitcoms not only do we get to
work with the brilliant chuck lorre he's
the master of comedy
um but i also get to work with this guy
over here thomas middleditch who's a
genius
and marco pinette is telling this
beautiful story from his life so
all the stars have aligned and we're
really honored and grateful that we get
to share
a story with the masses right now that
reminds us all to stay connected to love
each other to
to open our hearts to kindness and to
win be positive
like for real also it's not just the
title of the show it's an attitude
amen yeah it's an attitude it's the
title it's a blood type it's all the
things
so for both of you uh obviously we have
this pandemic going on how do you
do a tv show during a pandemic
there's a lot of hand washing there are
a lot of
masks and there are a lot of nasal swabs
thankfully we somehow have the the type
that only just
go in a little bit and don't like scoop
out your brain
along with it but uh but yeah you know
it's it's a lot of protocols everybody's
all the departments have these different
pods and all these um you know
safety protocols come into place if you
know something happens
but uh yeah it's obviously a different
way of shooting we don't have a live
audience
but um you know we're making do we
the show must go on as it were and my
guess would be that just the fact that
there is a show
to do that's got to be you know kind of
exciting too
uh emily i know that you have uh
performed in las vegas and tom's i'm
gonna get to you but emily tell me about
what you have done here in las vegas
i am honored to say that i have
performed at the smith center
um for a small residency twice it's one
of my favorite venues in the country the
best sound system
in america uh and las vegas is one of my
favorite audiences it was really a dream
come true getting to perform there
um i i ca i'm from denver originally and
we used to drive to vegas a lot and as a
kid that's where i would go to dance
conventions so
circus circus has a special place in my
heart in a way that
very few places do well circus circus
has a special place in all of our hearts
in the
thomas i did not know that you were do
they still have hot the big hot dogs
oh absolutely yes my mouth just so
that's right next door it's lots of fun
but we can talk about that later
thomas i didn't know that you are a
pilot and that you had a special visit
here to las vegas
yes i was very very lucky and i was
invited out to nellis air force base and
flew in an f-16
with the thunderbirds we did all kinds
of insane maneuvers i pulled nine g's
and i stayed awake the whole time
i barfed twice um and i made it back
safely and at one point
i even i even flew it a little bit but
by that time i was so sick that i just
sort of flew in a straight line
but uh yeah it was it was a dream come
true a dream come true
a dream came true through there's
undergrowth there you go perfect all
right hey before we go
with the subject of your show being
about a kidney donor i wanted to ask you
both personally have you thought about
organ donation after being part of the
show
yeah you know my mom is actually the
recipient of two cornea transplants so
i'm
very close to the land of organ donation
and always check the donor box
uh when i when i get my driver's license
and when my son was born
we donated the cord blood it's a really
easy thing to do my friends
um just just tell them when you get
there when i have this baby i want to
donate this cord blood it saves lives
it's awesome
i've got it on the driver's license as
well awesome all right so the show is
thursday nights right here on eight news
now be positive and
we're totally positive about the show
and thank you guys so much for
taking time to talk with us today and
we'll see you on the tube
take care thanks for having us